uh I'm sorry
Ernest Owens my big I do make a bum
um thank you very much very much for
joining me and now
much about you Ellen you read a piece
last week for Rolling Stone magazine
saying uh cancel culture is good for
democracy so I'm going to come to that
ludicrous premise in a minute uh but I
also remember you Tweeting when I uh
left Good Morning Britain uh a series of
tweets calling me a racist including
enjoying how folks keep getting Piers
Morgan together for his races to tirades
against Meghan Markle on Good Morning
Britain I was just curious could you
could you remember a single racist thing
that I said about her or I've ever said
about her
well thank you for having me on Pierce I
was surprised when I found out I would
be on your show again
we take all types
I I well all types well there you go
um but I think really a lot of it just
seemed to be biased I think that you was
really just harsh on um you know the
Duchess of Sussex and I think there was
a little bit of bias in the way that you
had really gone after her
I didn't ask you about that I just said
what were the racist tirades what what
racist thing I've ever said about Meghan
Markle I'm curious you you tweeted quite
a few times that I was a racist I'm just
curious what was the reason I said I
said your remarks I said your remarks
was racism
I think that it's biased I think that
you had a sense of bias of how you were
speaking about her and how you was
really being insensitive to her mentors
being biased or skeptical of some of her
claims is not the same as being racist
what was the thing I said that was wrong
I never hold on do you want the person
of color to speak or do you want to just
talk over me
sorry nothing to do with your skin color
I don't care if you're black or white
okay
try and tell me giving you tweeted to
your many followers
you did this repeatedly you have called
me a racist repeatedly for racist things
I've said about Megan
stand by watch you Tweeting what was it
I said about Megan would you let me talk
ever that's been racist
are you gonna let me talk are you just
gonna overtalk me
that's my progression you're asking a
black person to explain how what you did
could be perceived as racist and rather
than letting me finish talking you're
over talking and being highly defensive
am I being racist again this dog is
hollering right now am I being racist
again
okay you're being dismissive can can I
actually talk or maybe because you don't
answer the question on the show
okay so can I answer the question yes
you can please do
okay thank you okay so your targeting of
Meghan markle's mental health
gaslighting her specifically calling to
question the legitimacy of her claims
about the royal family being racist you
dismissing those claims you consistently
having a sense of badgering her and
targeting her it felt like on my end
that there was some racial bias there
now you may feel like it's not maybe a
sexism maybe it's misogyny maybe it's a
combination of both her gender and her
race but it was perceived by thousands
of people 57 000 people had called Good
Morning Britain about some of your
events
in a situation on Fox you act like it's
just making money but it wasn't just
making it
you do have to be careful when you spew
more lies unfortunately because fifty
seven thousand were people not spewing
lives I'm about to explain what you just
said was wrong a lie 57 or if you're
going to give your interview you're
gonna let me answer the question 50
seven thousand go ahead Pierce
Ernest 57 000 people complained to ofcom
the TV regulator and guess what five
months later every one of the complaints
was thrown out and oftcom found in my
favor to have my right to free speech
and freedom of expression but I come
back to my initial point about you you
repeatedly tweeted to many people that
I'm a racist and I'm simply asking you
comment
between racist comments so did I say a
racist tirade what was it
I felt like you're attacking if Morgan
Marco was racially biased oh you felt
right I believe you felt like it was
your feeling I felt that way it was your
feeling that I'm a racist was it
I felt like what you did was racially
insensitive I never said verbatim on
Twitter that you were racist I said you
made right you just said that you're
enjoying how things moving together for
his racist tirades but what's she
looking at your Tweet now Ernest and
there were plenty more in fact what I'm
talking to you will dig the others out
just go and dig them out folks um here's
my point Ernest the reason that people
think that I may have had a racist
connotation to my criticism of Meghan
markles because people like you high
profile black people in America kept
saying that without any evidence and now
I've got you on my show I'm finally able
to ask you why did you thought that was
about me you're blaming the black guy
don't blame me the black guy i'm blaming
you as a high-profile black man for
claiming wrongly well and defensively
in my motivation towards my criticism of
Meghan Markle which to be clear my
criticism of her and Prince Harry is I
think they both tell lies they both
recently said they didn't mean to call
the royal family racist
on National Television so my point to
you you can say these things you can say
these things on Twitter when you're
actually held to account said about
Meghan Markle yeah
and you've attacked Meghan Markle and
it's impacted her mental health and I
feel like someone like me as a black
person defending her as an innocent
black woman in that situation I felt
like I was standing up for her you need
to be accountable for your impact and
your power
you have a big influence and you're
trying to play a victory
and it was disrespectful no no Ernest
let me finish speak thinking I I've
listened to the Oprah Winfrey Show I
watched it and I identified immediately
a number of lies and I said that on air
the next morning other guests disagree
with me and you were delighted about the
way they came after me and that's fine
but then you said I was racist
repeatedly that my criticism was racist
racially motivated you're being
intellectually dishonest you did not
just say she was a liar you question
other aspects of her mental health
aspects of it I was offensive repeat
what you said I said I didn't repeat
what you said I said I didn't believe
her
why because there is no evidence to
support the claims that she made she
said she went to a senior moment
was no evidence Earnest I'm about to
tell you what I said
she said she went to a senior member of
Buckingham Palace staff and said she was
feeling suicidal and that member of
Staff said she couldn't get help
that story doesn't reappear in Harry's
415 page book and has never been
substantiated by anybody else nor has it
been repeatedly I'm afraid you did not
know that when you said sorry I didn't
believe it it didn't sound true and by
the way why you didn't believe that
Ernest why
and I'm also allowed to disbelieve you
when you call me a racist because it's
wrong and you shouldn't do it I said
that you made racist remarks I did not
call your racist peers you're trying to
make yourself a martyr in a situation
that you started you didn't have to go
disrespectful below the belt with Megan
you chose to do that
[Applause]
for what I thought was a disgusting
attack on the British royal family you
may add how many attacks against her
character you assassin her character
before the British press and you know
how the time you understood what you
were doing I've been just a scathing if
not more so against Prince Harry who I
actually think is more to blame
didn't you I want to know if this is
true X riddle me this wasn't our point
in time where at least you tried to
pursue a relationship with her you are
absolutely not before all of this
happening absolutely
it's another lie a matter once in my
life
okay
we found more tweets while we've been
talking to you are you calling me a
British media racist darling what does
that mean Ernest
what does that mean it means that you
have always you have recently chosen
lately in your career for whatever
reason you've went the road of basically
baiting into a lot of the bias coverage
of Meghan Markle absolutely this is a
problem a lot of them has been targeted
towards her in a biased way and and come
on can you admit that the coverage
around Meghan Markle has been racially
biased absolutely no I'm not talking
about your work no I think it's General
I think it's another load of absolute
hogwash nonsense so you're dismissing
the role of race in all of this you
don't think none this has a role I'm
saying the British media the British
media has never been racist about Meghan
Markle okay that's just a lie
it's a fact no it's not what is a lie
what is a lioness is you telling people
repeatedly I'm a racist and then you
can't produce any evidence other than
your female a racist High rate and
you're and you're and you're offended
but but here's the thing you're blaming
me for the criticism
you're blaming me for your criticism it
has nothing to do with your skin color
Earnest I don't care when you love the
black influential person you name my
race you said you're a black influential
person and that's why people thought
that way I think
I think when high-profile black people
like you
people believe it and you know what it's
a it's and people believe what you said
about Meghan Markle or no it's a lie
anyway we've got to leave it there and
it's been lovely catching up with you